how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about of course everything relating to
Marvel it's been a pretty unfortunate
past couple of weeks the film industry
has taken a really big hit during this
time of the corona virus many of the
movies that we were all really excited
and looking forward to coming out not
too long from now have unfortunately
been pushed back black widow being one
of them and as of last night Morbius as
well
Morbius has been pushed back to 2021
with no new release date and the same
with Black Widow no new release date yet
however I do have some good news for you
today
venom two is currently still on track to
be released on October 2nd of this year
Andy Serkis said last night that
everything is still on track all the
filming has been done and now all of the
editing and post-production is being
worked on remotely so fortunately for us
everything that they needed to get done
they've already gotten done and now
everything's just being done remotely so
it doesn't affect the actual release
schedule for the film and again that's
coming from the director himself but we
have more good news today as the trailer
for venom 2 should be coming very very
soon according to Deadline who was the
media outlet that reported that venom 2
is still on track
they are also reporting that the first
trailer for venom 2 could be with us
this week this makes perfect sense if
you caught my video I did a couple of
days ago I broke it down and I mentioned
that were actually do for the venom 2
trailer and right now while everybody is
quarantined and kind of forced to stay
home it's the perfect time to release
the trailer because it would get watched
probably the most out of any time right
now and it would certainly be more than
welcome at a time like this to cheer up
a lot of people so venom 2 is still on
track to come out on October 2nd and
according to Deadline we can expect the
trailer this week now of course the
corona virus could change things but
since they got all of the filming done
and our editing remotely that should
still stand we should get the trailer
this week the question is do you think
we'll see carnage in the teaser trailer
let me know if you think so in the
comments down below don't forget to
leave a like on the video and subscribe
when notifications turned on so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to Marvel and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll fluff
you